in a six-month investigation you'll see
only on CBS this morning we traveled to
the United States Air Force Academy in
Colorado Springs to investigate sexual
assault in the service academies the Air
Force Academy's stated mission is to
educate train and inspire men and women
to become officers of character in
service to our nation
but more than a dozen current and former
cadets have told CBS News they reported
their sexual assaults to the Air Force
Academy only to then experience
retaliation by their peers and their
commanders it was my dream school I
thought about it more and I was like I
love the Air Force I love the spirit of
core being a part of something so I was
really really excited when I got my
appointment it's one of the most
prestigious places you could ever go to
school you knew it's seven years old
that you wanted to go to the Air Force
Academy yeah I wanted to be a pilot it
was something you dreamed of your whole
life yep Emily Hazen was supposed to
graduate in 2015 as a commissioned
officer from the elite United States Air
Force Academy both she and Melissa Hilda
Meyer chose to abandon their military
careers after they were sexually
assaulted by fellow cadets I was
sexually assaulted my freshman year and
the sexual harassment her eventually
made me leave describe that harassment
my perpetrator would follow me on runs
he would tell me he urinated on my car
he would write crude things on my car
like in the fog he would send me
horrible text messages he would stalk me
he would ask me where I was going in my
little brown dress was he ever
reprimanded in any way he was talked to
by his commander about a very crude text
message I received and told that that
was unbecoming of an officer whatever
happened to that cadet he graduated and
what happened to you I left I intended
to keep it a secret Hill drew Meyer says
she was sexually assaulted by two fellow
cadets she admits they were all drinking
underage
she says they began to harass her and
she filed a report about the assault but
she told us agents based at the academy
with the Air Force Office of Special
Investigations had already made up their
mine's they would attack me they would
say things like these guys have every
reason to tell the truth and you have
every reason to lie and they were just
they made me feel like it was my fault
that this had happened to me like yes I
was drinking underage and I shouldn't
have been doing that but so were they
they were mm-hmm but it was my fault
that I got sexually assaulted power
cadets treated when they go public with
the sexual assault it is typically
negative Teresa Beasley was the Air
Force Academy's top official on sexual
assault prevention and response for ten
years
there are usually negative things set on
anonymous social media they're
ostracized frequently by their squad
mates and usually word spreads pretty
fast and word gets out who who is the
victim they'll have their name plates
taken off the room and throw it on the
ground people won't sit with them at
lunch how are they treated by their
commanders a lot of is depending on the
commander some commanders unfortunately
will begin retaliated on the cadet as
well that's why these current cadets are
risking their careers by speaking to us
about their sexual assaults he held me
he held me down while he yeah while he
assaulted me I am at some house I don't
know where I am and he is raping me
and then he I can't I can't fight him
off I can't do anything and I was going
to take it to my grave they requested
that we protect their identities there's
no understanding in the commander's
about sexual assault the trauma the
effects they don't know they don't
realize that when I'm depressed in my
bed it's not because oh I don't want to
go to class today I was terrified of
reporting because I've heard of things
that happened to people and that did
happen to me so it's not horror stories
that's slut-shaming it's victim blaming
it's rumors it's your career on the line
I've never wanted this all I've ever
wanted
do in my life was serve my country and
be one of the best officers that I could
be it's the most unfortunate thing you
go there because you want to protect
your country and they they don't protect
you
do you regret reporting the assault I
regret every day they came after I just
wish I never came forward cuz I never
asked to be assaulted
what would the Air Force lose if they
lost you someone who's passionate to be
in the to be in the uniform someone who
wants to say or country someone who
wants to lead America's young men and
women and protect our nation that's all
I wanted to do so imagine that America's
best and brightest women who want to
serve may leave because of this kind of
harassment the Air Force Academy tells
us that in the last five years 11 cadet
survivors of sexual assault decided to
leave one was over an honor violation
another for poor academics and a third
due to fitness deficiency eight
disenrolled voluntarily that means they
left on their own tomorrow we're gonna
hear more from Theresa Beasley who led
the Academy's sexual assault prevention
and resources office she raises concerns
about the way sexual assault cases at
the academy were handled and counted the
Air Force Academy also plans to respond
to our reporting in fact we're gonna
hear from its new superintendent
Lieutenant General J Silva era he's
gonna appear here tomorrow on CBS this
morning so glad you're telling this
story Nora I remember when you came back
and said imagine the talent that we're
losing and now I see exactly what you're
talking about but I don't understand why
the victim is ostracized and not the
perpetrator in these cases well that's
the issue and a lot of them a lot of
them file what are called sort of
private reports that then become made
public and so they've a face that
Australasian amongst their cadets and
colleagues and additional harassment
which is why some of them end up leaving
the Academy amazing work yeah nobody
hear the person say all I wanted to do
was just serve my country that's all I
want to do and now because these jerks
she's leaving and they get to success
yeah that is not right it's no sauce